معنا من مستشفى شفاء في مدينه غزه مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل نرصد معك
وتيره الاستهدافات كيف تبدو في الشمال
عموما
واثارها نعم في الواقع اليوم انسحبت قوات
الاحتلال من منطقه التفاح والدرج هذه
المنطقه التي استمرت بها العمليات قوات
الاحتلال لما يزيد عن ع ايام وهذه المنطقه
على غراء المناطق الاخرى تعرضت لدمار كبير
وايضا قوات الاحتلال جرفت المقابر وعملت
على دوس ال جثث الشهداء الذين دفنوا حديثا
باليات وهذا جريمه جديده تضاف لسجل قوات
الاحتلال لكن الدمار الكبير في هذا
المنطقه كان ملحوظا وقوات الاحتلال تعمدت
على تدمير هذه المنطقه علما ان هذه
المنطقه تعرضت قوات الاحتلال لضربات كثيره
من المقاومه الفلسطينيه ورسها كتائب
القسام من نقطه صفر ومن نقاط اخرى وحتى
خلف دبابات الاحتلال خرج المقاومون كما
ظهرت بعض الفيديوهات من كتائب القسام
اظهرت بعض الفيديوهات ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه دكت قوات الاحتلال في هذه
المنطقه بكثير من القذائف وتعرضت قوات
الاحتلال لكثير من الضربات والكمائن في
هذه المنطقه لكن الجديد في ايضا في مدينه
غزه ان قوات الاحتلال سمحت وا مره اخرى
تسمح بذهاب المواطنين من شمال قطاع غزه
الى جنوب قطاع غزه لكن لا ثقه لدى
المواطنين في هذه التصريحات وبعد ذهاب
صباح اليوم عدد من المواطنين الى المناطق
ال محاوله ذهابهم الى المناطق الجنوبيه
تعرضوا لاطلاق نار من دبابات الاحتلال
وقوات الاحتلال ولم يستطع احد الذهاب من
المناطق الشماليه الى المناطق الجنوبيه
هناك انعدام في او عدم رضا على هذه الخطوه
خاصه ان قوات الاحتلال ت تعهدت فيما قبل
ان المناطق الجنوبيه هي مناطق امنه لكن
الكثير من المواطنين الذين نزحوا من شمال
قطاع غزه تعرضوا لقصف عنيف في مناطق شمال
قطاع في المناطق جنوب قطاع غزه وبذلك
الكثير لا يريد الذهاب الى تلك المنطقه
ولا يوجد لديه ثقه في تصريحات قوات
الاحتلال وهناك اعتراض واضح على او هناك
ماساه واضحه في عدم قدره المواطنين
المتواجدين شمال غزه الى الذهاب والالتقاء
ب بعائلاتهم الذين حوصروا في تلك المنطقه
لشهور طويله بعد ان تعهدت قوات الاحتلال
ان تلك المنطقه هي منطقه امنه الان الحاجز
لا يستطيع احد الذهاب اليه على الرغم من
ان قوات الاحتلال تعهدت بانها منطقه امنه
تعرض المواطنون لاطلاق نار مباشر ولم
يستطع حتى هذه اللحظه ال احد الذهاب الى
تلك المنطقه و وفق تصريحات او شهادات بعض
المواطنون ان هذا الحاجز لم يشهد توافد من
المواطنين منذ صباح هذا اليوم بعد افتتاحه
من قوات الاحتلال ومن حاول الذهاب اؤكد
انه تعرض لاطلاق نار وهذه خطوه جديده
لقوات الاحتلال لاستمرار مسلسل التهجير من
شمال قطاع غزه الى جنوب قطاع غزه على
اعتبار انها منطقه امنه لكن الكثير قصفوا
في تلك المناطق والكثير من العائلات مسحت
من السجل المنطقه من السجل المدني في جنوب
قطاع
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك من مستشفى الشفاء في
مدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل غول
ومشاهدينا في خبر عاجل القسام تعلن
استهداف قوه صهيونيه as